很多人对短视频的理解都是错的
这条视频有点难
但是对应该非常有帮助
我看好多人就留量的交率
就不放量多少了
点赞又多少了
而且还发明出了一些什么
藏热点的方法
热点流量
都是短视频的资产
不是你的
你可以通过葱热点或者流量
别人也可以
所以美国一段时间就会出现一个热点
然后过一段时间就烧动机市
这个网红啊
是一场
介绍的
但是我来这个平台
已经很久了
所以各位好好想一想
你是在购片里的资产
还是为
平台的资产
浩妃你的清分
所以用户到那个时间打开手机是看刷短视频整好刷到你
还是打开手机就是为了刷你的
怎么做呢
给大家介绍三个
认知吧
首先第一个的话呢我发现很多人是有的中
就是融贸交路的
开本视频之前
一定要划个字啊
你一定要把这些收拾都没美的啊就不能需要一点点问题
各位
没人喜欢做料话
有的时候有一些小的瑕疵有一个巧班
反而会非常好
人们喜欢真实东西
原来这是一个真人
他是有温度的
所以真实很重要
第二个的话呢就是价值
就人们什么看短视频呢
比如是戒亚
比如说
修个扭体在啊
戒个飞造啊
可以看一个小时
干嘛戒亚吗
对吧
还有很年龄就是为了共情
哦原来
还有和我一样的人对吧或者是
快乐
我个人会选择给别人提供价值
因为这个价值是十足的
同时通过给别人提供价值
然后我可以购建我自己的
遇到什么问题的时候人们会想到你
第三个就是信任
我发现好的人
啊来
短明台就是为他卖货
什么还有那么一句话吗
直播的镜头就是带货
好像来都是为了赚赚钱的
生怕别人不满意的东西
可是有一个东西很重要啊就是信任啊
啊
收益成理优货书成肯富购
富购信任啊
你不要站在
用货的队地面
你要我成为他的
好友盲友军师
对不对
所以信任是非常重要的
我拍的这边拿下就拍
就是对于一些瑕疵比如说什么命论的此人啊
我觉得反而还挺好的
就是真实
第二个的话呢就是我在拍的这边之前一定会想
这条视频能给别人提供什么价值
这条视频拍出去以后是
和别人的关系拉近了
还是
属于来了
各位
短视频平台是
是一个内容分发的平台
它同时也是一个构件关系的平台
热点也好
留亮了一个好
那个不是你的
那是平台的这材
但是关系
是你的这材